[Musique]
ruben une histoire incroyable gérant
d'une société de dératisation
c'est ça s'arrête dans dératisation
c'est ça ça va ça se passe bien ça se
passe très bien et on a avec nous
également alors c'est paul ouais vous
êtes ancien dératiseur c'est ça pourquoi
vous avez arrêté qu'est ce qui s'est
passé par là et connu une très mauvaise
expérience
j'aimerais que vous nous raconter votre
histoire en fait je me réveille comme
tous les matins en fait je m'en vais et
des interventions dont vous avez vous
travaillé ensemble pour exactement très
bien donc on m'envoie une intervention
donc comme tous les matins je vais à
l'intervention donc c'est quoi une
intervention s'était ou dira où ça
s'éteint dans le quatrième à paris
d'accord dans une maison maintenant un
appartement mais au rez-de-chaussée
d'accord à côté il y avait un restaurant
d'accord et la dame affolée elle me dit
venez vite j'ai général j'ai peur donc
moi je me dis bon c'est pas grave c'est
comme d'habitude tout le monde a peur
même coach a bien sûr oui et je rentre
dans la cuisine enfin je fais mon
diagnostic tout ça je rends dans la
cuisine j'ouvre les placards il ya sans
mentir c'est tout ira qui sortent de
nulle pa alors c'était mon métier
bien sûr j'ai angoisses et j'ai eu très
peur je suis parti j'ai couru chez eux
mêmes peu j'ai atterri sur un canapé et
non les radis et dans toute la maison
une angoisse pas possible ils ont couru
dans que j'ai couru notre la maison au
moment où vous êtes le ghana qui court
après moi je voulais vous c'est un truc
de fou ils sont tous en fait comme la
dame et les avaient enfermés les
empêcher de sortir
il a ouvert le jeu moi j'ai ouvert le
placard
c'est thierry sol belge était tout seul
face à lui ras on passe à un lieu voilà
ura d'accord j'ai couru je sortais la
cuisine j'ai couru son canapé ils sont
ils sont partis dans toute la maison la
dame affolée elle crie partout allemand
goisses encore plus
non non non d'ouvrir la porte qui alors
acquis mac imac mac qui m'a frappé
l'agent mais il m'a mordu mais non et
partent panique j'ai pas j'ai pas tout
de suite
c'est le jeu c'est que j'ai eu mal
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire peut pas que
si mais j'ai fait j'ai justement je suis
rentré chez moi après j'ai vu que
j'avais mal et ça commençait à me lancer
j'ai eu peur pas du coup qu'est ce que
je suis fait je suis parti à l'hôpital
et ils m'ont fait un vaccin un vaccin
contre la rage et où ça fait mal lors un
bac en fait avec l'adrénaline comme j'ai
eu très peur
ma page et j'ai pas tout de suite senti
j'aime pas tout de suite sentiers mais
avec l'adrénaline j'ai pas eu ça mais ça
fait ça fait vraiment très peur ah oui
je vous sens et dans mort à serain ça
fait vraiment très peur et je vous
garantis et donc vous avez décidé
d'arrêter après when j'arrêtais baptisé
on va traumatiser du coup et pourquoi
alors qu'ici vous en train de me dire
alors parce que vous êtes dératiseur
ruben gérant d'une société de
dératisation c'est vrai ce que c'est
vrai que les rats ont beaucoup moins
peur des hommes maintenant bien sûr bas
comme mon technicien vous on était en
train de le raconter aujourd'hui de plus
en plus justement les rats n'ont plus
peur parce que déjà avec le l'histoire
du confinement en ce moment donc il y
avait plus personne dans les rues donc
ce qui a fait que justement en ce moment
l'une des races sont sentis chez eux
c'est ce à quoi j'ai vu j'ai senti chez
moi j'ai vu des chiens nous dominons
mais c'est vrai quoi les bras ils se
disaient ils ont plus peur ils ont plus
peur du tout ouais et m
et donc est ce qu'ils sont dangereux
serra ah oui très dangereux bien sûr
certains à dire c'est très dangereux
ces vecteurs de maladies donc c'est un
peu faux absolument rien sur déjà
vacciné contre contre la rage contre ça
ça peut amener beaucoup de maladies et
évidemment c'est très très dangereux
parce qu'encore il paraît que maintenant
ils s'aventurent de plus en plus dans
les habitations
avant il restait de loi mais pourquoi
ils vont maintenant dans les habitations
isabelle aussi oui on a on n'a pas eu
des censeurs pendant combien vue
dératisation mari car ils se sont
réfugiés dans laquelle deux censeurs et
on vous fait les câbles et les dons et
les personne ne voulait venir s'occuper
des rats qui ont proliféré dans la cage
de saint-just heures dans ma famille
nous avons subi récemment une attaque de
rafale et mangeraient sur la toile
le 15e arrondissement de paris un
appartement au dernier étage
c'est une cousine qui a ouvert la porte
de sa salle de bain et qui a vu un
énorme raz non juste au dessus des
toilettes donc c'est ça alors je vous le
dis parce pour les canalisations les
rails et vous il faut bien fermer la
cuvette j'avais dit à chaque fois et ça
c'est vrai parce que pouvez-vous mois
tient un pote à moi aussi réveillé la
nuit c'est pareil il avait un vin sur sa
cuvette joue lui retirait il m'a dit
comme ça exactement sans rigoler les
bouchons comme ça que je me sentais
selon le rac one comme ça en pauvre
gosse total le rat il arrive je vous
jure que c'est vrai c'est pas une il a
déménagé d'ailleurs il a eu tellement
peur qu'il a déménagé trading on avait
les toilettes
bah oui on ne parlait très belle
réalisation de buffles et ça ça arrive
très rarement les raboteurs du que nous
son programme sera très agressif très
agressif donc à la traîne a refermé la
porte une première équipe de
dératisation est venu c'était qui plane
était méchant combinaison ils sont
repartis sont revenus à 2-1 dans mes
combinaisons jure que c'est vrai nous
avons le goût c'est même hyper agressif
a une histoire de fous les rats en ce
moment à quoi cette équipe est à fond
parce que tout le monde y claira ils
peuvent prendre le contrôle de certaines
grandes villes et oui je vous le dis il
voit que de plus en plus les humains et
11h02 oui eh ben ils prennent la
confiance maintenir ciara vraiment lui
mettre un coup de chaud près voilà si
vous vous trouvez face à face et kara
faut pas faire genre on a peur c'est que
si tu arrives toi